hey this is really funny we only have
two bumper stickers that we sell okay we
have the david pakman show logo in black
and we have the david pakman show logo
in white if you go on our website the
david pakman.com slash gear those are
the only two bumper stickers that are
available Keith's contacted me over the
weekend because he was driving around in
Humboldt County California and he saw a
different david pakman show
bumper-sticker which were going to put
up on the screen for you which says
david pakman 2020 make america tell the
truth again this is hilarious because
someone printed this I mean we we this
is not a bumper sticker that we print I
wasn't born in the United States so I
can't even be President so I would not
waste time printing such a sticker but
someone made and is driving around in
Humboldt County California with the
David Pakman 2020 bumper sticker if you
know who this person is if you are this
person please get in touch and tell me
whether you've printed hundreds or
thousands of these things or if it was
just a one-off I've actually been to
Humboldt County California there was
once a one of our affiliate stations is
up in Humboldt County and it is like
serious cannabis country there are all
of these you have to hike to them to
make them hard for law enforcement to
reach I mean this was five years ago
maybe the changing law has has diffused
this a bit but you would see people with
refrigerator-sized backpacks walking
across roads rural roads like highway
one in areas where there's nothing
nearby to some of these cannabis
plantations and it's a big it at least
was a big cannabis area and at least one
person is driving around with a bumper
sticker that says David Pakman 2020 so
if you have more information about this
please let me know what car is it on is
this a single item who made it and we're
having all sorts of crazy things
happening behind me as well with our
April April Fool's thing so just to be
clear I think this is this is probably a
sign we have our joke Sam cedar logo
that we had on the back for April Fool's
and as soon as I'm talking about people
using my likeness without permission the
logo disappears and so I want to make it
clear I have no interest in pursuing
intellectual
property theft lawsuits or anything like
it and this is just a curiosity
wondering where the sticker came from
and love to see it get in touch if you
made that sticker